thanks for coming out quick show of
hands who here is from st. Louis like
natives awesome excellent so please
don't break our thing alright so today
we're here to talk to you about
something we've been working on for the
last year so but first off it's probably
a good idea to kind of give you an idea
of who we are the fun little map so my
name is Jonathan leek I'm a consultant
with Doherty business solutions my
backgrounds in organizational psychology
leadership psychology I've been doing a
lot of entrepreneurship started to
companies to nonprofits including the
local Code for America Brigade I'm Laura
again I'm currently employed by st.
Louis Development Corporation which is
the city's development arm kind of a
city agency but also a separate
nonprofit it's all very confusing for
the past couple years ago prior to
taking that position a couple months ago
I was working as a consultant to the
city on vacancy related efforts which I
somehow fell into after about a decade
of community-based conservation with a
focus on chimpanzees we can get into
that another time too but the general
themes of GIS mapping software and
managing projects I guess is how we link
in here and we both live in and love the
city yes ok so some context before we
move forward is this loud just just me
ok vacancy in general and st. Louis if
you live here you know it's a pretty hot
topic right now for some of us it's been
a hot topic for a while we're about to
top probably 8,000 vacant buildings
across the city and some were around
13,000 vacant lots but probably much
more and we'll get into that a little
bit later too depends on how you're
defining what a vacant lot is so if we
add those all up it's about 15% of all
the parcels across the city but this is
concentrated in North City so if we look
above the infamous Delmar divide 30
percent of all parcels are vacant and
abandoned properties south of Delmar is
only 3% so this is an issue that is
concentrated in North City after decades
of disinvestment redlining systemic
racism is taken decades to get to this
point it's going to take us a long time
to
our way out and it affects everything
not just for residents living in that
area but for the city as a whole so if
you live right next to it's going to
affect your property values but if
you're a city resident that's a built
influencing our city's ability to get
tax revenue to feed into all services
and improve our city as a whole so how
do we go about tackling this thing if we
don't fully understand it this is a big
topic lately so how many vacant
properties do we have where are they at
how did they come to be that way what
are the steps to get them out of there
this article was actually maybe last
week so this is an ongoing conversation
how do we measure our effectiveness as
we employ strategies to deal with this
issue and see if we are actually having
an impact moving the needle how do we
prioritize certain strategies in
tackling this so how do we pick
buildings out to be demolished versus
stabilized or renovated different
treatments for various vacant lots
and what does vacancy really mean what
term are we using collectively as a
community to define define a vacant
property so we're all on the same page
as we move forward so for example if we
were to take a definition of a vacant
lot as every parcel that doesn't have a
building on it we'd have about 40,000
vacant lots across the city but that
includes rights-of-ways people's yards
that are actively being used church
property common spaces university open
areas and so we need to start kind of
figuring out what do we mean by vacant
is it abandoned is it a burden to the
city or kind of all these things in
between and that's part of this
conversation too so those of you who are
from st. Louis know we have a very
active hackathon ecosystem so almost
exactly a year ago there was a hackathon
put on by open STL called build for STL
which is was designed to visualize this
vacant housing and start providing some
of these answers and we had a great
turnout like you can see 71 people went
to this I pulled this up yesterday but
we very quickly realized that none of
the teams were actually going to be able
to answer this problem and the issue
the data underlying the issue when we
got there it was a series of CSVs and
access files with unnamed columns
things weren't normalized we didn't know
how to join one thing to another
we had column names like parcel nine and
none of us knew what that meant
so how does this kind of thing happen we
hear this question a lot if you were
here at the pre-conference yesterday one
of the most common questions is how do
you help an organization that isn't
ready to be helped right so these data
problems come from a variety of things
but at the heart of it it's you have
their adaptations from legacy systems so
in the case of the city the city was
doing things with paper for a long time
and eventually somebody had a good idea
of we should start doing this with these
newfangled computers right but since
there was no IT struck formal IT
structure in place at the time they just
kind of built it themselves and so each
department kind of just started
developing their own thing independently
without communicating with any of the
other departments and on top of that
there is no formal change process so
anytime there's a change or an update it
just kind of happens it's not recorded
it's not communicated to anybody else
and then the folks that are doing this
are typically not trained in IT right
you have somebody who's like in the like
Laura's case is like you know
backgrounds in conservation
right so someone like her might be in
the forestry department and be like hey
we need a database to track all these
lawns up we're mowing and they'll just
put together what they can figure out
based off of you know some quick
googling on how Microsoft Access works
and then finally to compound all of this
it's difficult to get strategic and
support and funding for these things
because they're not sexy to average Joe
citizen right if I'm a politician and
I'm looking for a thing that's going to
help me get reelected database
architecture is not something that's
going to excite the voter base
I got to jump in there and defend my
friends in the city that they do but
there are a lot of really smart people
trying their hardest anyhow we're
getting there so what did we do we tried
this hackathon we failed we met each
other that day it was beautiful and so
we stepped out and started this project
on nights and weekends and that's what
we've been doing for many months now so
we took these data sets from different
departments that had lacking definitions
or didn't join to others or we weren't
sure what would join and just started
digging in and so we've taken 12
different data sets and merged them
together and we've created kind of a
profile for every parcel across the city
and we call that our parcel or
comprehensive parcel data set
there's about 130,000 parcels so it's
pretty small to 130,000 rows and it just
gets longer and longer and longer as we
add in these different pieces of
information from various departments so
from the Assessor we can get what's
going on with the tax situation and the
assessed value of the property but then
we can pull in about eight different
data sets from different areas of the
building division and see building
permits and demolition permits and
occupancy permits and there's actually a
vacant building survey done by
inspectors that can help feed into that
condemnation status and then we go over
to the forestry department which is
responsible for maintaining all vacant
properties across the city and they are
keeping track of every time a property's
mode or weeded or illegal trashing has
to be removed or how many board ups had
to be applied to that building and then
finally about half vacant properties in
the city are owned by our city's land
bank called the land reutilization
Authority it's the owner of last resort
and so we have their inventory
information and we also took what was a
PDF spreadsheet that people could look
at to find out the various prices of a
property if you wanted to buy them and
automated that and fed it into our
system with the help of open STL
shoutout alright so we pull all that
together and then we ask a bunch of
questions about well if this department
says this but this one says this what
are we concluding here so I'm just going
to give you one example of what that can
look like that picture probably doesn't
show up very well but here's a building
I think we could all agree it's probably
vacant it's got like a condemnation sign
in the front it's all boarded up and you
can see up to the sky so it doesn't have
a roof anymore but if we were to just
ask the database and kind of a normal if
we're doing this a quick and dirty if
you were like hey city how many vacant
buildings you have this would not show
up it's not marked as a vacant building
it's also not tax delinquent for some
reason they're still paying on this but
it is structurally condemned it has 10
outstanding building code violations and
we have record of and it's obvious here
that the the building division has
boarded up that property multiple times
so then we're going to call that a
vacant building in our data set right so
for our first attempts we tried to make
use of kind of what we had and what our
advantages were so we were operating
without official sanction like we
weren't like guerilla fighters by any
means like the city was more than
willing to work with us and answer
questions but it's not like the city
asked us to do this or my company put me
on this this was just something that we
did all nights and weekends because
we're nerds and people don't answer
texts about these things on like
Saturdays when were so but given that
situation there are some things that we
definitely had working for us right
because we are in this weird independent
status it's largely autocratic right so
when we have a discussion about what
defines vacant building rather than
having to like set up meetings and have
drawn-out conversations about who what
one person thinks should be vacant
versus another department we just kind
of decided and formalized it right it
really cuts down on the bureaucracy and
at the end we're able to deliver an
unexpected finished product that
provides value so like anything we
provide is going to be incredibly
welcome and they're gonna be really
grateful for because they had no idea it
was coming because nobody asked us to do
it there are bad things though like I
said there were the city was willing to
answer questions for us and provide
insight when asked sorry our timer
is disappearing but we didn't have their
day-to-day input which means we were
probably making some bad decisions along
the way right
we're also interpreting the data to the
best of our abilities and we've had
cases already where we found out that
like oh we assumed we made this
assumption that turned out to be invalid
this data actually represents something
other than what we thought but we do
have time so there's a data set called
occupancy permits you would think that
that's a permit to occupy a property but
it's not it's only for commercial
properties and there's something called
housing conservation district
inspections and that's occupancy of
residential properties so when we're
cross-referencing and saying it shows up
vacant but there was an occupancy permit
applied for and approved six months ago
so we're not going to mark it vacant
anymore
we were using the round data set the
first time around anyway we're also kind
of held back by limited tools resources
time right so anything anything that
gets pert any technologies that we
decide to use
either have to be free or I have to be
willing to pay for it out of pocket or
she has to be willing to pay for it out
of pocket right time is also an issue I
have a full-time job she has a full-time
job so this is getting shoved into
nights and weekends and you can't have
all of my nights and weekends I play
Dungeons and Dragons sometimes uh-huh
and all of these kind of combined into
the website itself when it's done does
provide a lot of value but it's kind of
slow it's kind of clunky it goes down if
you look at it funny because it's hosted
all these free services and it's it's
kind of patched together but one of the
things what we learned in this it's like
turns out done hides a lot of crimes so
we're gonna walk you through the website
really fast this used to be the front
page now it's it's buried under a layer
but if you go you will see these same
headings right some metrics map methods
and more okay metrics is going to
provide you with dashboards where you
can look at just
kind of raw numerical aggregate data so
right now we're just we're looking at
all right so we get an overview of how
many vacant buildings
how many vacant lots this number makes
me really mad at somebody who pays taxes
but just high-level overview and there
are different ones based off of
different dimensions so if you want to
look at just buildings you'll get a
different set of numbers to replicate
ball to buildings
same thing with lots and then we have
LRA owned versus privately owned so the
LRA is the Landry utilization Authority
that services the city land bank so if
the city forecloses on a building it
ends up in the LRA
and the LRA works to find a buyer for it
if you go into methods we describe
everything that we did so big important
part of this was to make this into
something that future developers could
use to facilitate their work so that way
if we have that visualization hackathon
again people aren't starting from
scratch so we made sure to document
every definition we provide a data
dictionary if you go to downloads it'll
give you you can download our data set
as a CSV or an excel file we also have a
even more detailed breakdown of the
methodology that is I think 18 pages is
that what it ended up at so but this
answers questions like what is a vacant
property here's the the download page so
you can see you can download the data
set we tell you when it was last updated
because right now that's still a manual
process we'll get to that we have a data
dictionary and then we have our full
methods where we break down exactly what
all works the heart of it is the map so
this was created in tableau and it's
hosted on tableau public for those of
you or no those tools it's not the ideal
tool but it's the one that I had it's
the one that I knew and I knew I could
get the work done quickly so we have an
outline of every vacant parcel within
the data set and it is color coded
based on whether it's a building or a
lot and basically our level of certainty
so whether it mostly fits our definition
or completely fits our definition and
then you've got filters so you can look
for a specific property buy address
ownership will allow you to toggle
between privately owned and LR a owner
will allow you to look for specific
owners so if you want to track down one
person's properties you can do so and
then neighborhood will let you filter by
a specific neighborhood so if you if
this is too overwhelming you just want
to look at the hill because that's where
you live that's how you can do it if you
click on any particular property you're
going to get a tool tip that's going to
provide you information about that
property and that tooltip is going to be
dynamic based on the nature of that
property so this is a vacant lot it
gives you the address who owns it
it's lra owns so it tells you how many
years they've owned it whether or not
it's available because sometimes like it
could be in the process of getting
purchased it might be designated for a
use so the lra owns it but they're not
willing to sell it for whatever reason
one of the big things we included was
the lra pricing so obviously the goal of
the lra is to sell these properties and
they have a pricing algorithm to
determine how much they charge based off
of usage so a side lot is like I want to
buy the vacant lot next door and
basically just extend my yard over there
right you also have a lot price a vacant
lot price a new construction price for I
want to build this by the slot and I
want to build something on it and then
finally like a vacant building price and
we provide links to two other resources
that might have further information
gos st. Louis and the LRA website both
of which might be able to give you some
more detail might be able to help you
purchase if you click on a building
you'll see you get something very
similar this is again an LRA owned
building but we have the biggest
difference is this plain English
description of the building and this is
really important for the average citizen
right because we want people to buy
these buildings people are interested in
does it have central air how many
bedrooms does it have
those types of questions we've put into
a plain English sentence to give you an
idea of basically how really haba ball
is this building and you can explore it
you can select multiple buildings filter
however you want and once you've found
kind of the data set you're interested
in there's a download button in that
bottom right-hand corner that allows you
to export the map that you're looking at
the raw data so if you want to import it
into some other tool that you work with
you can do that and that will give you
all of the data we have on that site not
just the stuff that's represented in the
map because there's a lot of data behind
this that never actually shows up on the
map right and if you're familiar with
tableau you can download the whole
workbook and just go to town on it I'm
sure you can probably you know take a
whack at it have fun with it so at the
same time that we're doing this things
are kind of gaining momentum around
conversations of vacancy and this
vacancy collaborative was forming and so
the idea is a group of external
organizations academic institutions
nonprofits Community Development
Corporation's that have interest in
dealing with this problem of vacancy and
also various city departments that in
some way interact which all of them do
working together on some collective
strategies the city can't solve this
problem itself either can neighborhood
organizations or developers so this
collaborative is kind of coming to
fruition the meat of it is working
groups that are cross sector where we
have folks from inside city government
and from outside working on things like
anti displacement reinvestment and reuse
stabilization and maintenance of
properties etc and so there was an event
on July 11th that was kind of the
kickoff of the idea of this
collaborative and we stole an hour of
that launch to reveal the site and
gather feedback from that and so we had
about 200 participants there
representing 80 different organizations
and
various types and so we put this website
out there and then broke out into small
groups had everyone break out their
laptops and tablets and we asked just
three questions what is useful about the
site and this information to you and
your job and your attempt to tackle this
problem what is missing from this and
what is unclear confusing or something
that we could work on and clarify and so
we use that time to gather feedback from
these 200 stakeholders that work on this
issue in the community but then also had
some press that kind of resulted from
that and got the word out even more
techie sorry so laughing cuz that guy
had a hard time on Channel five with his
little touchscreen system but so then we
started getting email feedback and and
people would be like you know you've got
this marked as vacant but it's actually
my community dog park or you know you
missed this building next door to me and
so now we're compiling all these case
studies where we can actually dig in and
be like why did we miss that property
and what can this tell us about our
larger methods so we can refine this
moving forward but aside from that we
can't say some good outcomes have come
and so I mentioned there's these working
groups of the vacancy collaborative and
we've expanded you know it's not just
the two of us and it hasn't been for
months working on this project and
that's grown into the data and analysis
working group of this vacancy
collaborative where we're gonna continue
working on this tool and others but also
be a source that these other groups
working on vacancy can come to when they
have data related questions or need
analysis or visualizations we've set up
a system with the building division
where at the same time they've improved
their system they now have inspectors
with tablets that are out there and can
put real time information about vacant
buildings whereas we used to do an
annual paper survey and so now every
time a building comes up as maybe in our
system we can shoot it over to them and
they can spend it send an inspector out
double check and if it is mark it and
next time we update our data set that
comes in there and so we're trying to
get that worked out so we can keep the
information flowing open STL has been
increasingly involved and is working on
some other side projects and various
city departments are more and more
engaged we might be tapping
two datasets will an already one that
aren't necessarily on like the city's
open data portal or accessible but also
getting some definitions clarified and
moving that partnership forward and I
wasn't supposed to do this live less I
know your names on it
okay well then but we thought we were
gonna take all that feedback and by like
September we'd have the next iteration
out you know by the end of the year it's
gonna be automated and we're gonna just
let a computer around the show and move
on that did not happen so now we've you
know the website is not just what we
just showed you it's expanding to be
more comprehensive and actually be the
landing page for this vacancy
collaborative and other tools as they're
developed are being and will continue to
be added to it dealing with people
asking us about it a lot from various
places so now if you go to the site it
actually has three different kind of
directions you can go more information
about the vacancy collaborative the
portal or based on immediate request a
demo tracker so now there's an
interactive map of all demolitions of
vacant and abandoned buildings across
the city that's updated at anytime you
can see ones that are completed this
year that are in progress right now that
are coming soon and if you click on a
dot it tells you where the money is
coming from who the contractor is and so
kind of getting sidetracked a lot we're
using the information to help prioritize
those demolitions so if we can tell you
how many times we've had to board it up
or how many times it's need to be weeded
and it's condemned to kind of start to
piece these things together we can start
to get a priority list and then working
with other departments to go and ground
truth that information a little bit
further but it gives us a good starting
point for picking buildings that might
need to go versus might need to be
stabilized definitely started a larger
conversation about what it is we call a
vacant property our definition was
pretty tight we focused on properties
that represents some sort of burden to
the city so if there's a lot that
doesn't have a building on it but we've
never had to go remove trash or weed it
or mow it
fine who cares someone's maintaining it
does that really should we be concerned
about that as a city and so we only
counted those that required some sort of
investment resources from from the city
itself still make good so other folks
are already kind of taking this
information in doing side projects and
as we continue to refine the methods we
hope those projects will improve as well
one example is there are studies from
other cities that tell us the kind of
try to quantify the impact on property
values of living their vacant properties
and so as we really hone and define
where these are we're taking that
information and and applying those
methods to st. Louis to get an actual
representation of what this is costing
us both as someone who lives near nearby
but also the city as a whole and
fielding requests from different
government departments and academic
groups that are like what is this can
you explain it to me more how can I use
it and so we'll see what comes out of
that all right so where do we go from
here
first is we're working on refining the
portal automating all of the data
ingestion and processing and providing
an API a lot of you are probably
thinking why didn't you start with that
well those parts are hard and we wanted
to provide immediate value to the city
and it turns out we can provide value to
the city without doing the hard parts we
want to expand a new data sets on
completely unrelated to vacancy so we've
been working exploring a public/private
partnership in order to facilitate
redoing all of the data the city's data
architecture not just vacancy but across
10 different departments
and the idea is kind of twofold like one
it's gonna massively improve how things
function in the city and from like the
private side like if as as a citizen
that wants to help the city this is a
one-stop-shop for improving everything
that the city does right I could work on
vacancy I could work on crime I could
work on an unemployment but if I fix the
data I'm not gonna fix any of those but
I'm going to empower the people that
know a lot more than I do
to be more effective and I can therefore
improve all of them and and so to that
end my company Doherty is now putting
together an inception workshop to kind
of scope out what that would look like
and how much work would be involved and
we're trying to figure out okay how do
we fund that right how do we how do we
make this all happen so if you're
interested in doing this there's parts
of this that are easy and there are
parts of this that are kind of hard
turns out it's really easy to get
individual people excited and willing to
help you help your community you just
kind of have to ask and people will step
in and help also helpful the data all
the data that we built this off of our
public so nobody we're not having to
jump through hoops to get access to data
to make this happen we're having to work
a little bit to understand it and to
make use of it but the data is there
it's just in CSVs on the city's open
portal site we can just do whatever we
want with it
and we've been able to use our
independence to to really push this
forward and drive this and make it
happen
stuff that's a little more difficult if
you try to tack a tackle a civic product
project it can be kind of hard to find
or define that project right the only
reason I was able to work on this is
because I happened to meet Laura who
understood vacancy and the data involved
really really well and was able to guide
us through the domain expertise required
to do this it's difficult to gain
support and funding it's one of the
reasons we did this very duct tape
e-version to start with um because it's
easier to gain that support and that
funding once you've established the
value of it but again for Joe citizen
it's gonna be really hard for them to
understand the importance of a proper
data architecture a proper data
infrastructure underneath and a lot of
times people just kind of assume it's
better than it actually is
when our new mayor came into office the
first thing she asked for was to see all
the dashboards and we like the city like
the employees just had to look at her
and be like those don't exist like you
can ask these questions you can ask a
question like how
many vacant buildings are there and it's
gonna take us two or three days to
answer that and the answer is probably
not going to be with a high level of
confidence so one of the lessons we've
kind of learned from this one important
one people don't read documentation um
so we have a 12-page methods document
and still the number one question that
we get from the website is why is this
building vacant or why is this building
not vacant we're working to create
better visualization to better make that
more apparent but if you're gonna work
on something like this probably from the
start keep in mind that nobody's going
to read anything you write give them a
cartoon all right
sustainability is really hard we've all
been to hackathons and this was brought
up during Shawn's talk yesterday
hackathons are a great way to start a
project and never finish it right you
worked really hard on it for a weekend
and then it just kind of evaporates um
getting that sustained work done over
the course of months years it's really
really difficult and don't underestimate
it and if you can get that part right
you can mess up almost everything else
and you'll still produce something of
value that increased support and
collaboration as the project grows and
as you kind of prove the value comes at
a cost of decreased productivity right
so since that launch my development time
on the website itself has gone to almost
zero because any time I have to work on
this project I end up working on
strategic level issues or you know talk
meetings talking to the press like I
there's only so many hours I can give to
this and unfortunately those are the
things that are taking up time now but
you have a potential greater impact
right so all that time with the press
seems like a waste of time until you
realize that this website's only useful
if people know about it right and so
every time we show up on the news or in
the post-dispatch the websites becoming
more useful even if it's not improving
right and then it's easier to ask for
fine mint then
census so we bootstrapped this it's like
I said very duct tape II but the
important part was we did it and then we
asked for refinement rather than from
the start
hey we want to do this doing requirement
gathering getting trying to build
consensus about a definition for vacancy
right so a simple thing like how do you
define vacant building that can be just
hours upon hours upon hours of meetings
and arguments and email chains or you
can just pick one make one up and use it
and then when people have problems with
its kind of discussed from there but
then you're starting from a starting
point right it's the difference between
editing your paper and writing it from
scratch just get it down and probably
the most important thing is there's a
better way to volunteer guys we
everybody in this room we're all
technical people and we're all so I'm
assuming civic minded like everybody
that's in this room I'm assuming you're
here because you want to learn how to
make a difference in your community and
it's very easy to volunteer at a soup
kitchen or Habitat for Humanity or
whatever and do just kind of the manual
labor II parts and those are providing
value but you know we can do more we can
just load the way same way this
technology has allowed business to scale
we can allow our volunteers of the scale
and so I would encourage everybody here
to look for ways that you can use the
skills that you have to improve your
community and now I don't know how much
time we have well
early questions
[Music]
right and I think that that was the
important part of asking for a
refinement instead of buying from day
one so every city's gonna be different
but I think what was really important in
our process was not going to the powers
that be until we had a product to share
and saying what do you think yeah yeah
could this be useful do you want to be
involved you want us to launch this just
as citizens doing a side thing and they
were like nah we wanted what more data
do you need you know but it wasn't until
we had something to look at it otherwise
it's a waste of time to have these
hypothetical conversations about what
you may or may not provide yeah so in a
more concrete example for your use case
would be rather than coming to the city
and asking for a change in process come
to them and be like we built you this
app we want you to use this to collect
data now because your papers are
annoying
[Music]
we get a lot of like how what if we want
to click on a property and input our own
information are like upload a photo or
say found one you know put it in the
system and right now we're really
focused on how do we automate what we
have because this is we're always
chasing our tail right so property
ownership changes and inspections come
in and condemnation zand and out and so
what we're trying to focus on right now
anyway is is a constant single source of
truth of where every vacant property is
that's updated automatically and when we
get to that point then how do we feed in
input and kind of ground efforts if that
answers your question
so hopefully yes but we want to get past
this phase one first wrong finger oh
thank you I'm gonna answer that one no
we you know we have this conversation
with people a lot actually about you
know if you're just taking all the
information that there is and turning
around and pushing it out into the world
without any kind of framing or context
and even the definitions though could be
a framing and it's used in ways you
don't like does that mean you should
have not shared the information from a
conservation background people talk
about should we not share where the
chimps are because then like poachers
could go and find it and you know drop
little nukes on that area and these are
this is the same conversation like
information sharing that can have
negative consequences do we then hide
information and I think the approach
that we've taken is information needs to
be shared period we need government
transparency and at the same time though
I will say personally we have feelings
and so like I serve on the anti
displacement working group of the
vacancy collaborative and that's another
conversation that's happening at the
same time is it
if this information is used for
redevelopment reinvestment how do we
ensure that's being done in the right
way you want to add anything to that my
job is just going to talk about that
anti displacement crib the vacancy
collaborative as a whole consists of
several different working groups based
off of different subject matters we're
primarily talking about the data and
analytics group right now which mostly
serves to support the other working
groups but one of them is the anti
displacement and they are specifically
looking at that problem because we
recognize that that is potentially
problem we don't want that to happen but
we also don't want 2000 acres of vacant
land to sit and be a public health and
safety and crime and quality of life
drain on the residents that it's been
impacting for decades so we have to find
a way to balance that - and we need this
information regardless are we out of
time or do we keep going okay one more
see your hand in the back
yeah mayor later Kristen has been
incredibly supportive of this the
hackathon that originally kicked all
this off was kind of at her request this
was the subject matter and as we've been
going about it like we've she's been
showing this at when she talks about
this problem with the press
she's been including us as part of her
strategic plan going forward she's a
very busy woman so like the politicians
tend not to get involved too deeply but
from a strategic level having
politicians that are in support of this
project and men are making it a priority
makes it easier for all of the non
politician city employees to give us
their time to give us their resources
because it's it's part of this
administration level initiative okay
thank you
[Applause]